10 trillion dollars right this is
breaking news blackrock launching an
institutional trust for spot bitcoin
exposure i'm going to bring it out
podcast host bitcoin expert leah halpern
uh in atlanta of course you have often
talked about institutions getting
involved in this so how big is this news
this is incredibly bullish news you have
to consider the current climate that
we're in right now right now we are in a
bear market we're at the beginning of a
recession and of course despite the cpi
numbers coming out yesterday inflation
is still soaring and yet the world's
largest asset manager wants to give
exposure to bitcoin this is truly
incredible also we have to consider the
fact that bitcoin is only 13 years old
it's this new digital asset and many
people still regard it as that risk on
asset and during um times like this
where and there's a lot of political and
economic instability globally people
tend to sell their riskiest assets first
and actually move to things like gold
and more blue chicks more blue chip
stocks and so right now this really
shows us that there's huge demands these
the smart money sees tremendous value in
bitcoin as this global payments network
any hesitation at all though we just had
a discussion about you know the esg
movement how black rock and others are
using that and listen let's face it i
mean you know they the entire country uh
is is
holding on by a threat because of the
this i mean
any worries at all i know there's got to
be some legitimacy that's where all the
big money is to move the needle but are
you any concerns at all
in terms of the esg narrative i have no
concerns whatsoever because for the very
first time bitcoin is i'm an asset which
can be mined um anywhere in the world
using renewable energy the amount of
energy that's actually being used to
mine bitcoin in that renewable way which
of course is better for the environment
is increasing there are major um
companies and mining companies like iris
energy for example they actually um mine
bitcoin using 100 renewable energy and
so if you uh were to completely
disregard this and still push that esg
narrative that would be very
intellectually lazy in my opinion let me
say on on on the uh political stuff for
a second because you've become louder
and louder on some of these social
issues and you recently elicited the
five biggest scams and democracy is on
the list why is that a scam
well to be clear i don't think democracy
in and of itself is a scam i think uh
the current form of democracy that we
have is a scam i think we have a
democratic deficit in the united kingdom
for example we have a two-party system
that's not democracy that's a democratic
deficit in the u.s you have a population
of 330 million people and the best you
could come up with is uh biden and trump
that's not democracy that's the worst of
two evils we also have to look at this
uh organization which seems to be taking
uh having a lot of control right now
which is the world economic forum uh the
chairman of the world economic forum
clash rob has actually said that his
goal is to have individuals who are part
of their organization implemented in
cabinets all over the world this
includes biden who in the u.s he's world
economic forum it includes boris johnson
it includes uh macron in france and it
also includes uh jacinda arden in new
zealand and um and trudeau in canada so
the goal here is to have one kind of
global agenda implemented by one
centralized um entity in europe that's
not democracy that's uh that's our one
global agenda which is very very
concerning yeah and you're talking about
the davos folks does this uh add
credence though or even urgency to the
to the notion of bitcoin
and a decentralized uh revolution
i love this question charles absolutely
bitcoin is the only form of money which
is truly decentralized it empowers um
not just money but it empowers um a
decentralized mentality understanding
that anything centralized cannot be
trusted bitcoin is this trustless
network whereby you don't have to put
your trust into any centralized entity
whether it's a central bank and whatever
it is so absolutely bitcoin is that a
mentality which i really believe it
empowers hey i gotta go uh but i do
wanna uh you know the last couple times
you've been on you got the energy but
you're not at rambunctious you're not
telling me a hundred thousand u.s
dollars a million u.s dollars i mean
what's up with that i mean is it still
gonna go to the moon
oh it's still going to the moon i'm
still very bullish but i'm also
realistic we are in a bear market and so
no i don't think we're gonna see one
million dollar bitcoin tomorrow or a
hundred thousand dollar bitcoin tomorrow
but yes in the in the next uh in the
next 10 years 100 bitcoin is already up
400
in the last two years so long term i'm
always bullish but i'm realistic we're
in a bear market right now and i think
bitcoin is holding up pretty good right
now yeah it's holding up really well
especially breaking through 24 thousand
leia's always a pleasure thank you very
much